hello
if this is working um
which i'll find out already found out
that i can't get it to work yet
on periscope um
this is me doing a small
run through um reading something
the weather here has been so strange all
morning
uh giant storms
and just as this went online the sun
came out
which is why and the strange
white figure and why the lights in the
background
are kind of washed out but that's not
going to be a problem
at seven o'clock and may not be a
problem in 30 seconds because
um the sun may go away and the storm
may be back and the problem will
probably be hearing me
and because i wanted to try reading
something
long enough i thought i would read
a poem and this is a poem
that
i wrote um
probably 15
20 years ago now
um and it's a
poem that exists for this time of year
and it's called the scorpio boys in the
city of lux
sing their strange songs
the scorpio boys in the city of lux
sing their strange songs smear the
windows of your car with
cheap rags piss on your doorstep it's
lucky to see them
if you see them you won't die today
there's an old man he's all that status
an end of the world the end of the world
knocks on his door once or twice a week
they have cake and tea and a chat and
crumpets in the winter
and a battle of wits so far the old man
is winning the world only ends
every now and again we don't remember
ending
we're from this go round oh they stare
the scorpio boys it's an act of magic of
course if you believe in them at all
if you see them you'll be lucky
so damn lucky
beaten up and left for dead by the
pilt-down men
singing we are we are the built down men
we are
we are they stumble down the roads of
the cities of twilight breaking bottles
and puking in gutters
someone finds you and picks you up and
carries you home maybe it was us
you never know a cigarette traces the
shape
in the air something made out of light
and smoke
so you know it's magical someone says
it's lucky
and who knows what will happen stranger
things happen in cities
even small cities take lux
for example a city that isn't even there
like of cities it is a magical
description awaking
impossible things happen a distance
like a poem or a whisper or a sort of
filled with ink
you can stare into it or dip your pen
either way it will take you to invisible
place
open a door in your heart a sharp nosed
and shabby genteel
with ink spots and cinder burns on our
clothes
when there are enough of us we become a
city
doing it because we believe in it
because the stories need to be described
and come to us for their faces
there and i've learned to make sure that
nothing was blip bingo bong
while i'm reunite but probably tonight
or mostly
from books by candlelight
okay now to find out if any of this at
all
thank you for watching if you've been
watching